et pour en parler nous sommes avec
olivia zemor présidente d'europalestine
palestine qui va évidemment nous
apporter un un avis et sans doute
contradictoire par rapport à l'invité
précédent jarret flash n'est requis et
donc reçu par quelques membres de l'onu
aujourd'hui de manière totalement
informelle pour présenter ce plan de
paix vous attendez quoi tu ses membres
de l'onu aujourd'hui
pas grand chose écoutez on aimerait
qu'ils aient au moins le courage de dire
comme la procureure générale de la cour
pénale internationale qu'israël de toute
évidence a commis des crimes et que les
palestiniens ont le droit à la liberté
et à la justice et au respect du droit
international c'est à dire que leurs
propres résolutions qui ont été donc
voté à l'onu que les conventions de
genève qu'elle soit mise en accord avec
la réalité c'est à dire que des
sanctions qu'ils soient prises qui n'a
jamais été le cas parce que c'est bien
de voter des résolutions pour dire que
les palestiniens ont le droit à leur
territoire qu'ils ont le droit de
revenir les réfugiés palestiniens
vivre sur leurs terres mais et de
condamner les massacres israéliens ou le
camp de concentration qui se trouve à
gaza
mais s'il n'y a pas de sanctions de
prises et a aucune raison pour que
l'occupant israélien
art est d'occuper de coloniser d'annexer
comme on le voit aujourd'hui est
bombardé des populations civiles
l'invité précédent charles meyer vice
président de l'association france israël
on a bien compris que vous étiez
totalement opposés dans votre
association europalestine à ses
positions lui déploré le fait que
mahmoud abbas négativement jamais
voulu négocier avec les israéliens vous
répondez quoi
déjà que je vais pas répondre et
discuter avec quelqu'un qui nie qui est
une occupation qui nique et une
colonisation qui nique
israël est expulsé plus de 800000
palestiniens en 48
alors on sait très bien que israël ne
veut ni de deux états qui soit viable
l'un et l'autre et ce qui voudrait dire
supprimer les enlever les colons qui
sont dans les colonies mais ces colonies
qui sont illégales au regard du droit
international et israël ne veut pas non
plus ce qui serait pourtant une solution
à mon avis raisonnable d'un seul état
avec les mêmes droits pour tous quelle
que soit la religion des uns et des
autres donc qu'est-ce qui refuse de
négocier quand on ferme toutes les
portes et qu'on dit jérusalem
c'est à moi tout est à moi les colonies
c'est pas des colonies c'est pas ça fait
partie de notre territoire
je vous vois pas ce qu'est ce qu'on peut
discuter c'est vrai que dans ce plan de
paix en panne de solution à deux états
du bout des lèvres quand même pour la
première fois donald trump on parle ils
évoquaient effectivement la capitale de
jérusalem est tellement clairement ces
cités mais alors après qu'on n'y croit
pas qu'on se dise voilà c'est une
c'est une manoeuvre c'est une chose mais
il ya quand même quelques pistes non
tout est à rejeter pour vous maintenant
on sait qu'il n'a jamais proposé que
jérusalem est soit la capitale des
palestiniens il a proposé au contraire
il a dit ça doit rester une et
indivisible et être à israël jérusalem
c'est ce qu'a dit david trump donald
trump et c'est ce qu'il dit dans son
fameux plan de paix qui est un plan
d'annexion il dit ça serait à bout dit
ce qui serait la capitale et à bout
disent je vais vous dire c'est vous avez
qu à dire ça va être sarcelles qui va
devenir à la pl la capitale de la france
je veux dire bon si vous estimez que
c'est pareil que jérusalem je crois pas
et donc la nécessité d'avoir deux états
il annexe il serait pour l'annexion non
seulement il donnerait tout jérusalem à
israël
contrairement au droit international
mais en plus il annexe serait la vallée
du jourdain
ce qui est 60% du territoire de la
cisjordanie quand même aujourd'hui on
sent même question quel invité précédent
ensemble le discours est totalement
bloquée on a peine à croire que ce plan
puisse aboutir est ce que clairement les
pays notamment européens ont un rôle à
jouer
selon vous sur ce dossier
d'intermédiaire bien sûr c'est un rôle
qui devrait jouer depuis longtemps et on
a vu pour le moment en france aucun
gouvernement qu'ils se disent de gauche
ou de droite
le faire c'est de faire respecter les
résolutions qui l'ont votée à l'onu
les conventions de genève qui l'ont
signé et donc de prendre des sanctions
parce qu'on voit bien que quand on dit
simplement je suis pour deux états
israël continue à faire exactement ce
qu'il veut et à coloniser à prendre plus
de territoire à chasser des palestiniens
ou à les enfermer donc les sanctions se
dire que nos états sont capables d'en
prendre
on le voit à l'encontre d'un certain
nombre de pays nous on ne demande pas
que on bombarde la population
israélienne
mais il ya des privilèges qui sont
données sur le plan économique à israël
comme si c'était un pays européens par
exemple israël ne payent aucune taxe à
l'exportation de ces produits
c'est un privilège énorme il ya une
collaboration militaire une
collaboration à tous les niveaux il y a
même la possibilité pour les français
qui le souhaitent d'aller servir dans
l'armée d'occupation israélienne d'y
commettre des crimes et de revenir
tranquillement france si vous faisiez la
même chose en syrie je pense qu'ils
auraient des problèmes et bien toutes
ces choses là devraient commencer par
être supprimée et tant que dure
l'occupation l'apartheid la colonisation
il faut des sanctions et on a bien vu
que les paroles
les paroles ne suffisent pas donc là en
plus si maintenant monsieur mâcon sommet
a salué les efforts de paix de monsieur
trump
alors que son c'est une vraie
déclaration de guerre je ne crois pas
que ça fasse beaucoup avancer les choses
merci en tout cas
olivia zemor présidente d'euro
palestine se précise pour nos
téléspectateurs qui ont droit à la
vérité qu'il était compliqué de vous
revenir sur le même plateau voilà on
voulait faire un débat on n'a pas réussi
nous devrions voter fait clairement
dialoguer avec leurs airs en sable d'une
association qui soutient la ldj la ligue
de défense juive qui a démenti ce
menteur orist les choses sont dites ça
est dommageable on aurait aimé
confronter vos deux arguments mais voilà
on respecte ce choix on doit la
transparence à notre insu la terre merci
je vous remets d'âge c'est moi qui vous
remercie merci au revoir